madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition aux etats-unis le congrès a voté
la très grande majorité la divulgation
mondial sur internet du rapport mettant
tous bill clinton
la douma a voté aujourd'hui
l'investiture de gainey primakov le pays
se dote d'un premier ministre après
plusieurs semaines sans gouvernement
page spéciale dans ce journal avec
amoussou de nos envoyés spéciaux
louis le pensec ministre de
l'agriculture annonce une série d' aide
aux éleveurs de porcs les éleveurs la
juste insuffisante la fête de l'humanité
à la courneuve tout ce week-end de
reportage dans une section de militants
de la région parisienne
le président américain affirmait il ya
peu qu'il vivait les jours les plus
difficiles de son existence depuis la
fin de l'après-midi le congrès a voté à
une très large majorité la divulgation
mondial sur internet d'une partie du
rapport de kenneth starr qui met en
cause bill clinton un fait qui n'a pas
de précédent tant dans la forme que dans
le fond le film de cette journée aux
états unis phil hughes aso à la
cathédrale de washington pour la messe
donnée en mémoire des victimes des
attentats anti américains bill clinton
ne fait pas les choses à moitié
son côté pathétique sa contrition
s'inscrivent dans sa stratégie du
repentir hier c'était à washington
avant-hier en floride aujourd'hui 7 à la
maison blanche devant les leaders
religieux
je sais qu'il n'ya pas de façon élégante
de dire que j'ai péché c'est important
pour moi que tous ceux qui ont été
blessés
sache que mes regrets sont sincères en
premier lieu le plus important c'est ma
famille mes amis mon équipe face au bond
gaminet master monica lewinsky et sa
famille et le peuple américain je leur
ai demandé à tous leurs barres de hier
soir un puissant renfort qui était resté
jusqu alors silencieux est venu une fois
encore à sa rescousse celle
qu'attendaient les démocrates
fidèle hilary a défendu son président je
suis fier de son autorité je suis fier
de son mandat je suis fier de ce qu'il
donnait son pays et à chacun de nous à
chaque jour par sommation avant que la
commission judiciaire du congrès ne
donne son avis sur la suite à donner au
rapport star il reste plusieurs semaines
que le camp du président pourrait bien
mettre à profit pour toucher voire
ébranlé l'opinion
63% des américains pensent aujourd'hui
qu'il ne doit pas être destitué 61%
qu'il ne doit pas démissionner qu'il a
fait une erreur
normalement je ne pense pas que ça c'est
que sa capacité à conduire le pays reste
à savoir à présent si le rapport de
kenneth starr qui devrait être rendu
public sur internet dans les minutes qui
viennent sera de nature ou non à faire
changer l'opinion et à washington nous
vous rejoignons tout petit philippe
gassot vous disiez le rapport sera
divulgué sur internet dans les heures
qui viennent pourtant dès ce matin de
larges extraits ont été publiés dans la
presse et notamment dans le washington
post
voyez-les quelques extraits et on a eu
l'impression nous les journalistes en
poste ici à washington qu'il s'agissait
plutôt de voir écrite des rumeurs qu'on
connaissait déjà depuis pas mal de temps
on a lu ce matin dans washington post
que par exemple bill clinton avait reçu
une douzaine de fois dans son bureau
ovale de la maison blanche monica
lewinsky et qu'il s'était vu de très
près on va même un peu plus loin dans ce
journal on indique que lorsqu'il avait
des jeux interdits par la morale de la
main droite avec monica ils appelaient
de la main gauche un haut personnage du
congrès qui est derrière moi et dans le
genre un tout petit peu compliqué du
président on indique d'autres jeux que
je préfère ne pas commenter ici nous
avons appris il ya quelques instants que
la maison blanche réfute est le rapport
de kenneth starr en publiant un document
de 73 pages est ce que vous savez de
quel document il s'agit eh bien écoutez
c'est d'abord une stratégie vous savez
entre kenneth starr et la maison blanche
c'est une guerre de stratégie alors
sortir le document ça veut dire devant
l'opinion américaine
eh bien nous n'avons pas eu le document
original
nous ne pouvons pas nous défendre mais
nous avons eu quelques rumeurs sur
lesquels nous allons parler
et il est question notamment dans ses 73
pages de du parjure du président
lorsqu'on lui a demandé monsieur le
président vous avez eu des relations
sexuelles avec monica il a répondu face
caméra vous vous en souvenez il a
répondu non et bien dans ce document que
je n'ai encore pas lui on dit par
exemple que le président ne sait pas par
juré que simplement la question a été
mal posé et qu'il ne s'agissait pas du
tout du problème qui était évoqué si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire merci
philippe gassot nous vous le disions les
démocrates ont voté aussi à la très
grande majorité la publication sur
internet du rapport du procureur
cette semaine quelques grands leaders de
cette formation ont pris leurs distances
vis-à-vis de bill clinton
pourtant aujourd'hui les militants de
base tente de resserrer les rangs
dominique derda devant la gare geraldine
ferraro fait campagne pour les élections
sénatoriales
candidate malheureuse au poste de vice
président aux côtés de walter mondale en
1984 jerry comme l'appellent ses
supporters est l'une des grandes figures
du parti démocrate et à l'heure où à
washington beaucoup dans son propre
parti considère désormais bill clinton
comme un pestiféré qu'il faut fuir elle
ne renie rien de son admiration pour un
président qu'elle a contribué par deux
fois à faire élire
après les primaires il doit venir ici
pour nous aider à collecter des fonds
c'est déjà prévu et non seulement c'est
prévu mais nous avons tout fait pour ça
et nous nous réjouissons vraiment de sa
venue parce qu'il est fabuleux vous
n'essayez pas de prendre vos distances
non pourquoi vous croyez que je devrai
me méfier de lui
à son état major de campagne au beau
milieu de la nuit on tient le même
discours
le rapport de canet star n'est pas
encore rendu public mais quoi qu'ils
contiennent on absout par avance bill
clinton de ses péchés admis à vous moi
personnellement je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'ils m'aiment ans si on n'a pas encore
prouvé qu'il ait menti il a peut-être
oublié de nous dire des choses mais je
ne peux pas croire qu'il n'est pas dit
la vérité
alors vous lui pardonner je l'autorisent
tout simplement être humain dans un
petit restaurant du quartier branché de
chelsea geraldine ferraro on retrouve
des militants démocrates de toujours dit
d'être me faire paraît détendu c'est
parce que les sondages de la candidate
sont gros
mais quand on en vient à vivre une bonne
personne le cash sa déception
ce qui m'inquiète moi c'est qu'il est
était assez bête pour revoir cette
liaison alors que politiquement c'était
absolument qu'on sait que ça risquait de
mettre le reste des combats qui l'ont
fait et ils tous ces démocrates n'espère
plus qu'une chose que les excuses mille
fois répétés du président suffisent à le
sauver jusqu'à la fin de son mandat et
que son parti pour sa succession se
trouve un candidat vierge de tout
reproche voyons à présent de quelle
façon la classe politique française
comprenait ou réagissait à cette affaire
lewinsky propos recueillis par arnaud
bouteille et yann streiff il y encore
quelques semaines ces images faisait
sourire aujourd'hui la classe politique
française s'inquiète elle craint les
répercussions de la crise à droite comme
à gauche on dénonce pêle-mêle les excès
de l'amérique
si vous êtes un fidèle ça va
l'intéresser absolument personne mais si
vous êtes président des états unis
la gestion devient illégal puisque un
acte qui serait complètement anodin
venant d'une personne anodine devient un
crime majeur quand il s'agit d'un
puissant
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un procureur a le
droit pour assouvir son intégrisme de
mettre en péril la sécurité la paix
économique dans le monde
nous allons au devant de graves
catastrophes est ce que l'opinion
américaine est suffisamment informé le
procureur star et la majorité
républicaine voudrait que l'état les
juges les pouvoirs puisse s'immiscer
dans la vie privée d'une personne
président ou non alors que chacun a
droit à son jardin secret andré kaspi
balaie d'un revers de main l'indignation
des hommes politiques ce spécialiste des
états unis rappelle que bill clinton
s'est servi de sa famille pour conquérir
le pouvoir
comme tous les présidents américains il
connaissait les risques
à partir du moment j'utilise leurs
familles cela veut bien dire que leur
vie privée n'existe pas leur vie privée
est un outil il va de soi qu en
conséquence lorsque cette vie privée
fait l'objet d'accusations
ils ne peuvent pas à ce moment-là
l'exclure de la vie politique
scandale des missions en france ce
scénario ne s'est jamais produit en
amérique si c'était il ya plus de vingt
ans avec le watergate et le départ de
nixon et nous retrouvons maintenant à
washington simon serfaty bonsoir vous
êtes politologue le président américain
multiplie les confessions et les mea
culpa tout à l'heure encore il a
présenté ses excuses à monica levinsky
plus qu'une stratégie est ce que c'est
un aveu de faiblesse qui pourrait lui
porter préjudice
oui c'est un aveu auquel ne peut pas
échapper mais ce faisant évidemment il
est affaibli il est affaibli de plus en
plus politiquement puisque sa base
l'abandonnent moralement puisqu'il
confirme un certain penchant franchement
pour le mensonge et surtout
administrativement puisqu'il n'est plus
à même de gouverner la priorité des
priorités pour lui et la survie parce
que la destitution vous paraît désormais
une hypothèse probable pas probable
c'est encore très prématuré son grand
avantage pour le président clinton et
l'affection qu'on lui porte
on aime les mets à linverse de nixon que
l'on aimait détester je crois que sur la
base des sondages qui lui restent
favorables
il a la possibilité de se défendre et
l'entente le faire je suppose bien que
on va ausculter de très près cette
opinion publique dans les heures qui
viennent et ce sera décisif
tout à fait c'est décisif
il ya une petite fragilisation qui
commence à s'amorcer dans la mesure
précisément où le public américain qui
lui rend hommage comme président
constate qu'il y as détérioration des
conjonctures conjoncture locale
économique mais aussi conjoncture
internationale et cela pourrait
également contribué à l'affaiblir alors
en france monsieur sarfati on a un peu
de mal à comprendre la gr
été des événements il si on regarde les
choses avec une certaine indulgence
on a tort et oui je crois franchement
les français comprennent de l'amérique
aussi mal que les américains ne
comprennent la france
les américains au long de leur histoire
se sont fait une certaine idée de la
présidence cette idée était franchement
bafouée elles étaient bafoués au fil des
années au fil des mots fil des semaines
et on estime qu'il est un peu tard pour
clinton dorénavant de s'excuser de ce
qu'il n'aurait pas dû faire en premier
lieu merci mais c'est sa fatigue d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct de
washington
venons en maintenant à la russie qui met
un terme provisoirement en tout cas à la
crise politique qui secouait le pays
avec l'investiture cet après-midi de
gainey primakov la douma une très large
majorité a désigné au poste de premier
ministre cet ancien apparatchik chef de
la diplomatie soutenus par l'opposition
notamment par les communistes une
solution de compromis
gilles rabin dida du monde politique
russe primakov ancien patron des
services secrets connaît toutes les
bassesses et toutes les compromissions
c'est sans doute pourquoi il n'a même
pas pris la peine de faire un vrai
discours il s'est contenté d'énoncer
quelques principes d'action avant
d'avancer qu'il ne prendrait pas de le
chef de parti dans son gouvernement et
des professionnels quelle que soit leur
appartenance politique
et si vous n'êtes pas vraiment décidé à
me soutenir dans les mois qui viennent
ne votez pas pour moi
la pièce était jouée d'avancé et le vote
acquis et si le leader communiste
duganov déclare avoir gagné sa guerre
contre le kr est allé à la télévision
sur la toile s'enrichit hassine estimé
ne pas avoir perdu
le plus important c'est que ceux des mac
os n'est pas l'un de ces hommes
malléable il ne sera pas manipuler même
par le président la tension est retombée
d'un coup il n'y avait plus
aujourd'hui deux banderoles devant la
douma ceux qui étaient là l'été souvent
par hasard
aujourd'hui ils ont enfin trouvé un
gouvernement bis - ma copine n'est pas
venu à notre rendez vous
alors peut-être que le sort de mon pays
bien aimé 20 média l'oubli hydra been
vous êtes à moscou la russie semble
provisoirement sortir de l'impasse
politique marquant tout passage
l'affaiblissement des tableaux de boris
eltsine
oui tout à fait au prix de
l'affaiblissement de boris elstine mais
aussi de ses adversaires politiques et
d'abord les communistes qui ont laissé
croire aux russes un temps qu'il voulait
le pouvoir et ont fini par reculer
devant l'ampleur du désastre économique
alors bien sûr il restera de cette très
longue et très grave crise politique que
pour la première fois le zar goris a
reculé
c'est bien une fin de règne qui
s'annonce dans la douleur et il faudra
attendre pour savoir si la russie elle
en sortira gagnante un jours merci
gilles rabin dans une quinzaine de
minutes nous reviendrons très largement
sur les événements qui se déroulent en
russie nos équipes d'envoyés spéciaux
avec gilles rabin et emmenée par benoît
duquesne vous proposerons dans le
dernier tiers de ce journal une page
spéciale l'extrême nervosité des places
boursières et notamment celle de
francfort particulièrement sensible aux
événements qui se déroulent à moscou
l'allemagne payent le prix fort de la
crise politique et économique russe
l'ambiance à francfort jean-paul
chapelle olivier robert les boursiers
sont de plus en plus irritables depuis
un mois francfort a perdu le quart de sa
valeur
plus de 1600 milliards de francs partis
en fumée apparemment un problème de
diffusion ne reviendront peut-être sur
ce sujet de jean paul chapelle que nous
allons tenter de rejoindre en direct de
francfort je ne sais pas si la liaison
fonctionne jean-paul vous n'entendez
bonsoir bonsoir nous reviendrons sur
votre sujet en tout cas les marchés
boursiers n'avaient pas besoin des
nouveaux développements de la firme
unica les biscuits aux états unis est-ce
que vous ressentez déjà sur place à
francfort une onde de choc
c'est vrai que les marchés ont horreur
de l'incertitude et la possible
destitution du président américain
rajoute un risque supplémentaire cela
dit le vrai risque pour les états unis
c'est pas celui là c'est le risque c'est
que des pays d'amérique latine craque à
leur tour comme en russie un peu pour
les mêmes raisons à savoir des pays qui
ont connu une forte croissance mais qui
n'ont pas une assise financière solide
on a vu à sao-paulo hier la principale
bourse d'amérique latine qui a perdu
près de 15% dans la journée dans la
panique et le mouvement ne peut que
s'accélérer
il revenait bien sûr à l'investiture de
primakov à moscou est ce que le nouveau
premier ministre peut apaiser la
tournante seulement provisoirement parce
que l'allemagne reste en première ligne
on l'a vu ces pays qui a le plus prêter
à la russie ont tout ça représente 100
milliards de francs alors 100 milliards
de francs qui ont peu de chances d'être
remboursé cela dit bien sûr ces crédits
bancaires ont été couverts provisionné
il ya des assurances publiques qui l'ont
couvert mais au final c'est le budget
donc le contribuable allemand qui va
devoir payer ces 100 milliards de francs
et c'est pas rien c'est l'équivalent du
trou de notre crédit lyonnais
merci jean paul chapelle ham ou encore
pour vous dire vous parlez de
l'agitation sur les places boursières à
wall street à new york les cotations
sont toujours en cours mais la bourse a
clôturé hier à moi 3,2 pour cent
aujourd'hui tokyo plonge d'un peu plus
de 5% francfort 0,1 pour cent en fait à
paris la bourse a fini la séance sur une
baisse de 0 31%
en france le ministre de l'agriculture
louis le pensec à proposer aujourd'hui
une série de mesures destinées à aider
les éleveurs de porcs d'abord à travers
un prêt de 420 millions de francs
davance de trésorerie par ailleurs 100
millions de francs seront débloqués pour
les éleveurs en difficulté
enfin un report de paiement pour les
charges sociales sera consentie les
éleveurs de porcs ne se disent pas
satisfaits des mesures qu'ils jugent
insuffisante dans un climat de détresse
jusqu'aujourd'hui le cours du porc a
atteint son plus bas prix depuis 25 ans
voyant les réactions à ces aides
consenties par louis le pensec reportage
en ille et vilaine
olivier sio gabriel camilla toute la
matinée michel cheval a attendu de
nouvelles de paris et des fameuses
mesures dead annoncé ce midi par le
ministre
l'agriculture des mesures qui comme les
avances de trésorerie remboursables lui
semble aller dans le bon sens même si
michel avoue être un peu resté sur sa
faim
je suis un petit peu déçu parce que il
ya une enveloppe de 420 millions de
francs
mais malheureusement au niveau d'un
élevage de 1500 tri ça ne fera que
quelques 60 mille francs
et est ce que ces 60 mille francs
suffiront pour emmener les gens alors
que la crise de la fac s'amplifier dans
les semaines à venir mais pourtant face
à la crise le monde syndical ne fait pas
forcément front commun et pour la
confédération paysanne qui a rencontré
cet après midi louis le pensec les aides
doivent d'abord allé aux exploitations
les plus fragiles et non aux élevages
quasi industrielle qui se sont parfois
développé dans l'illégalité nous faut
absolument qu à chaque fois qu'ils un
éleveur en difficulté on peine tous les
moyens pour les maintenir et que si une
diminution de production il doit y avoir
si bien dans les grands élevages et
surtout dans la partie illégales
ce qui doit qu'on doit supprimer la
production au niveau communautaire
l'europe justement les éleveurs
entendent bien obtenir aussi des
avancées de bruxelles au motif que
désormais la crise n'a plus de
frontières
aujourd'hui la crise n'est pas française
la crise est bien européenne touche à
tous les bassins de production
aujourd'hui européens sont confrontés à
cette crise donc il me semble j'irai
sans doute impensable que la commission
la semaine prochaine ne comprennent pas
ou que le ministre ne comprennent pas ce
prochaine qui a urgence de prendre des
décisions au niveau européen et six
ministres et commission ne le
comprennent pas les éleveurs de porcs
eux ont bien l'intention de continuer à
se rappeler à leur bon souvenir
la hausse des prix en france a été de 0
2% au mois d'août après une baisse de
0,4 pour cent en juillet les prix de
détail sont légèrement en hausse sur les
douze derniers mois +0 7% selon les
chiffres provisoires de l'insee en corse
après la publication du rapport
parlementaire mettant en cause la
gestion de lille voyant la réaction sur
place de quelques élus locaux qui disent
n'avoir rien à se reprocher l'autre sans
père patrick desmulie
l'indispensable sursaut le titre du
rapport des parlementaires à la une de
la presse locale
aujourd'hui ce qui est frappant dans
l'île c'est la réaction des élus locaux
à la lecture des paragraphes très sévère
les concernant aucun n'a sursauter ils
sont et pas du tout visé par sa contre
attaque il ya dans ce rapport non je ne
me sens pas visé je dirais même que j'ai
trouvé des éléments de satisfaction les
nationalistes est également critiquée
retient avant tout les reproches
adressés à l'état et l'ironie sur la
mise en cause des élus locaux
paris fait mine de se rendre compte
aujourd'hui les turpitudes de ses élus
qui moyennant leur allégeance totale à
la france n'importe quoi en corse
seul le président du conseil général de
haute-corse développe un discours plus
nuancé
c'est peut-être que nous avons les uns
et les autres manqué de responsabilité
aussi par exemple
j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir commis de
faute pénale j'ai le sentiment depuis 15
ans je suis mère ou 17 ans je devrais
clame à cor et à cri et parfois le mavi
l'application des lois de la république
et publiquement mais j'en ai peut-être
pas fait assez diamant aussi après celle
qu'on pouvait aller plus loin et bien
maintenant je dis que ce document est
excellent il parle du passé il est très
bien il faut qu'il parle aussi de
l'avenir faut qu'on se retrousse les
manches
il faut qu'on obtienne que cette île se
redresse tous les élus de lille souligne
la qualité du rapport d' enquête mais
chacun semble en faire sa lecture en
oubliant les critiques
le projet de pacte civil de solidarité
continue d'enflammer les esprits après
les déclarations hier du nouvel
archevêque de lyon monseigneur billets
président de la conférence épiscopale et
réaction sans tranchée se fier mais elle
le mariage en danger la famille affaibli
fabre et la prise de position d'
associations familiales catholiques
c'est au tour de l'église de se
prononcer contre le pac qui prévoit de
donner un cadre légal notamment en
matière sociale et fiscale aux couples
non mariés qu'ils soient hétérosexuels
ou homosexuels
et c'est bien là que le bât blesse pour
certains comme ou seigneur lui y énonce
une légalisation déguisée du mariage
homosexuel
on ne peut pas ignorer qu'en fait cette
cette loi aurait aura été si elle passe
voulue comme un premier pas dans une
direction que nous nous connaissons ces
propos ont provoqué un vif émoi dans les
milieux homosexuels
si les associations ont préféré se
concerter avant de réagir
jean qui vit avec eric depuis huit ans
c'est personnellement montré très choqué
légaliser l'homosexualité moi j'ai pas
l'impression d'être un criminel en
légaliser le cannabis
ces détails complètement déplacé ou sa
religion dit que dieu est amour et
tolérance et là en l'occurrence c'est
l'intolérance à l'état pur les opposants
du pacs ni voit souvent qu'une mascarade
de mariage un pied de nez à
l'institution républicaine
ce contrat pourrait pourtant demain s'il
est entériné concerner des millions de
citoyens
ce n'est pas un texte destiné aux
homosexuels mais à tous les français car
nous ont bien la différence entre
l'individu et le citoyen l'état n'a pas
à se mêler de la vie et des gens
cette proposition de loi sera présenté
le 9 octobre devant l'assemblée
nationale
on sait déjà aujourd'hui d'après les
sondages une majorité de français se
prononce en sa faveur
la fête de l'humanité traditionnel
rendez-vous des militants à la courneuve
alban nicosie eric de l'agneau ont suivi
cette semaine une section de communistes
de la région parisienne en préparant la
fête ils débattent sur l'avenir du parti
avec cette question récurrente comment
être au gouvernement et au parti
communiste
romainville cité youri gagarine
c'est pas le genre de quartier qui
figurent dans les guides touristiques
nous sommes mardi et c'est le jour du
porte à porte nous sommes dans un
bastion du pc dont les candidats sont
régulièrement élu au premier tour
pour les militants ces journées juste
avant la fêtes sont l'occasion d'écouter
les électeurs ceux notamment qui
trouvent que le gouvernement mène une
politique pas assez à gauche les années
nous en tant que communiste
on n'est pas forcément toujours très à
l'aise par rapport à ce qui ce
gouvernement qui ne correspond pas
forcément à la tant qu'on peut avoir
nous si on veut arriver au changement
dans les gens souhaitent
eh bien je crois que les gens il faut
qu'ils s'en mêle tout simplement
alors pour infléchir la politique du
gouvernement
la section de romainville multiplient
tracts et pétitions pour un relèvement
du smic
par exemple en ce milieu de semaine les
militants vont aussi à la courneuve
préparer leur stand pour la fête de
l'huma avoir des ministres au
gouvernement est une chose
oubliés ses convictions une hausse même
si cela donne lieu à un feu de patinage
au sein de la majorité
c'est nous qui faisons avancer le dans
notre bataille qui devrait faire avancer
les choses
on peut pas laisser nos ministres ou des
ministres le faire tout seul
hier soir le stand était fin prêt la
convivialité traditionnel respecter mais
les militants de romainville attendent
de la direction du parti non seulement
qu elle les écoute mais surtout qu'elle
les entends la ville de sète dans
l'hérault privés d'eau potable depuis
cet après midi les orages du début de la
semaine sont à l'origine d'une pollution
bactériologique a annoncé la mairie la
municipalité recommande de boire de
l'eau minérale de l'eau bouillie les
analyses pratiquées pourrait durer 48
heures
nouveau développement dans l' affaire
qui oppose richard virenque et le
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme daniel baal daniel bas
l'accusent de coureurs de festina de
l'avoir menacé des propos qui sont
fantaisistes répond le champion philippe
visseyrias nathanaël de rincquesen
chaque matin lorsque l'équipe festina se
présente au départ c'est vers lui que
les supporters se dirige sur le tour
d'espagne
richard virenque n'a rien perdu de sa
popularité
mais son retour en france s'annonce
difficile dernier épisode du feuilleton
festina daniel balle président de la
fédération française de cyclisme affirme
que richard virenque la menacer d'après
lui le coureur voudrait faire courir le
bruit selon lequel daniel balle
autrefois cyclistes amateurs se serait
dopé dans sa jeunesse
et puis ça a été
l'autre menace en disant je vous
s'allierait à titre personnel bon comme
je lui répondu mon problème n'est pas
d'être salis à titre personnel surtout
si les arguments utilisés sont vraiment
pas très bas très intéressant ce matin
richard virenque a démenti avoir tenu de
tels propos
on a disputé leurs deux choses et vote
mais quand même hein verbruggen s'est
bien passé aujourd'hui dire que je vais
me lancer
c'est surprenant tout récent tout ce qui
se passe est surprenante
ce bras de fer psychologique se produit
à un moment crucial pour le coureur
l'union cycliste internationale a
demandé à la fédération française de
prendre des sanctions exemplaires contre
les cinq français de l'équipe festina
impliqué dans le scandale du dopage
richard virenque risque de six à douze
mois de suspension il pourrait ne pas
être retenu en équipe de france pour
disputer les championnats du monde en
octobre prochain
la commission de discipline doit
entendre virenque dès son retour
d'espagne dans un climat on le voit loin
d'être serein
spectaculaire collision grand prix
multicoque de royan le trimaran vert et
blanc de franck cammas a été violemment
percuté par le bateau de francis joyon
les des gaz importants le flotteur du
bateau de cammas a été endommagée ce qui
pourrait remettre enfin sa participation
départ de la route du rhum en novembre
prochain
en effet retour l'étranger en iran
bruits de bottes la frontière avec
l'afghanistan des manoeuvres militaires
avec cet après midi des avions
militaires iraniens qui ont atterri au
centre de l'afghanistan l'iran qui a
annoncé son intention de se venger du
meurtre des diplomates par les talibans
extrême tension en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens après la mort
de deux des chefs militaires du
mouvement ramasse abattu par un commando
israélien
le mouvement intégriste a juré de les
venger sans lendemain
c'était la brocheuse le plus sérieux de
la journée il a opposé l'armée
israélienne à des jeunes lanceurs de
pierres à l'entrée d'une implantation
près de ramallah
la police palestinienne a dispersé les
manifestants
pas de violence au cours de défilé
d'islamistes à la pelouse et à gaza
partout les mêmes slogans vengeance
vengeance est aussi riposte at elle
admis la cisjordanie et gaza sont
bouclés lors que dans tous les lieux
publics d'israël la sécurité a été
renforcée
les menaces du hamas sont prises très au
sérieux adèle awadalla était le chef de
la branche militaire du mouvement
intégriste
il a été tué hier soir ici près de
hébron en compagnie de son frère imad
évadés d'une prison palestinienne le
mois dernier tous deux étaient accusés
d'avoir organisé des attentats faisant
21 morts israéliens à jérusalem amer le
troisième frère lui aussi détenu par la
police de yasser arafat a été libéré ce
matin
ils accusent les services spéciaux
palestiniens d'avoir collaboré avec les
israéliens lui aussi jure qu il se
vengera
je vous propose maintenant cette page
spéciale consacrée aux événements qui se
déroulent en russie nos équipes
d'envoyés spéciaux aux côtés de notre
correspondant permanent vont nous faire
vivre et comprendre comment à moscou et
à l'extérieur de la capitale la
population ressent la crise économique
mais d'abord voyons comment
l'investiture de gagner
primakov a été ressentie aujourd'hui le
film de la journée nous retrouvons
benoît duquesne
bonsoir nous sommes devant la maison
blanche c'est ici qu'en 1993 glory celle
ci avait dû recourir à l'armée au char
pour dénouer la dernière grande crise
politique est connue la russie cette
fois-ci vous savez le scénario n'a pas
été de même avec l'arrivée au troisième
tour
l'arrivée in extremis et presque
surprise d'evgeny primakov à l'homme on
vous disais tout à l'heure de qu'on
produit un homme en tout cas d'appareils
qui a connu quasiment tous les
dirigeants et tous les régimes et qui a
connu aussi les services secrets ce qui
fait de lui quelqu'un à la fois de
respecter mes deux redoutée par la
classe dirigeante politique
alors dès que la nouvelle a été connue
et bien didier dalleau dorothée olliéric
et 30 blessés ont voulu se rendre dans
une banlieue de moscou pour voir comment
cette annonce avait été apprécié
amos où la rue de la paix et si tu
regardes ses modèles ici ville
professeur architectes les commerçants
la classe moyenne nationale
mais pas question de monter avant
d'avoir interrogé la consigne diables
rouges prime abord il est 21h lors des
animations la famille mais on ne sait
pas encore quand je me suis marié la
veille de la crise cei
je suis parti deux semaines en vacances
est en voyage quand je suis rentré à
moscou
j'ai retrouvé un autre pays j'étais
vraiment en état de choc
je n'en suis toujours pas revenu le vois
bien comme beaucoup de moscovites est en
pleine dépression à cause de la crise
quand je vois ce que ces vieilles femmes
qui n'ont pas d'argent et ne peuvent
rien acheter ce amnesia d'ogeu partage
vraiment leur souffrance
sk primakov paris cette crise enfin ça
c'est vraiment difficile de répondre à
cette question
franchement moi je doute mais je crois
pas que ça va calmer nombre
à quelques kilomètres de là dans la nuit
moscovite les jeunes comme si la crise
n'existait pas
bien sûr la vodka est plus cher mais
pour ressortir s'accrocher à leur
liberté lui vaut mieux jeter quand ya
quelques jours cassivi
on respire je crois qu'on est passé à
côté le châtelet passé même une seule
seconde que le rideau de fer allait
retomber
je ne le peux pas je ne veux pas
maintenant qu'on connaît cette ville et
les bars et tout on pourra pas y
renoncer
il ya sept ans il n'y avait ni barney
discothèque à moscou pour ceux qui ont
20 ans 7 ans c'est une éternité
l'autre réaction très attendu à cette
décision des politiques de la douma
c'est bien sûr celle des financiers
autrement dit des oligarques comme on
les appelle ici ces hommes qui tiennent
en quelque sorte et que denis russe et
qui se sont enrichis dans des
proportions incroyables en l'espace de
seulement quelques années et bien a
priori cette décision est plutôt bien
apprécié pas forcément parce qu'ils
pensent que l'économie va se redresser
mais au moins parce que distille cela
met fin à l'instabilité politique
alors nous avons dû avec rango risques
et progresser et didier gelin dans une
des rares bons qui accepte et nous
recevoir et curieux que c'est peut-être
la seule qui tire à peu près son épingle
du jeu et vous allez le voir la
situation financière est toujours très
délicat réunion d'investissement dans
une grande banque de moscou
ici la crise russe on l'analyse on
l'anticipait de son évolution dépendront
les bénéfices éventuels ou surtout les
pertes est ici l'arrivée de frima coffre
est perçu comme une bonne nouvelle c'est
une très bonne nouvelle que si l'on
tient compte du fait que la russie lui
quand il sent gouvernement préval depuis
des semaines weeks oui mais ce que je
redoute c'est que primakov on est une
formation de macroéconomie et qu'il ne
connaît pas réellement le fonctionnement
des marchés
la plupart des analystes sont anglo
saxons ou bien russe formée dans les
grandes écoles occidentales
c'est peut-être pour ça qu alpha bank
est une des rares à résister à la
mi-août du système bancaire
thierry malleray fait partie de ses
finances il averti dont les avis sont
aussitôt répercutée aux investisseurs
étrangers
nicolas aussi les perspectives sont
extrêmement sombres que les mois qui
viennent parce que le pays est en train
de s'enfoncer dans les terres inflation
l'expérimentation se termine toujours
mal à la dislocation d'économie des
troubles sociaux le cas échéant car si
alpha bank ne s'en sort pas trop mal
elle a quand même licencié la moitié de
son personnel
quant aux autres banques elle s'est
élancée avec le gouvernement dans une
espèce de folles cavalerie aujourd'hui
elles ferment les unes après les autres
et les épargnants ne peuvent même plus
retirer leur argent
on leur a confié toutes nos économies et
aujourd'hui ils ne veulent pas me donner
d'argent et puis je me dois le caniveau
mois glee ne délivre que des reçus
pendant ses années de libéralisme
débridé quentin dollars s'investissent
et en russie dix autres quitter le pays
quelques-uns ayant trouvé fortune les
autres doivent payer la note
alors on l'a vu dans ce reportage sont
les classes moyennes les petites gens et
d'une façon générale tous les
travailleurs d'état qui sont le plus
touchés par la crise qu'ils soient
fonctionnaires ou surtout retraités pour
lesquels la situation est encore pire
eh bien pourquoi et bien tout simplement
parce que leurs salaires sont dérisoires
et parce que ces salaires ne sont pas
toujours verser en tout cas pas verser
dans les temps il faut attendre quelques
fois un mois deux mois voire plusieurs
années dans les cas extrêmes
alors que fait-on eh bien on se
débrouille les courants ici de voir des
gens et bien effectué une autre journée
travail après leur journée de travail
coct officiel de roter olliéric et et
didier deshamps ont suivi un couple et
deux diplomates en retraite sous
gorbatchev c'était les privilégiés
aujourd'hui il leur faut aussi se
débrouiller sur les murs de leur petit
appartement les souvenirs d'une vidéo le
couple a connu le cambodge l'italie le
maroc ou encore la france surtout d'eux
faisait partie du sérail lui était
ambassadeur de l'ex urss aujourd'hui ils
sont des retraités presque comme les
autres
ils vivent avec une fonction de 500
francs par mois avec votre retraite
moment j'attends que de la nourriture
de temps en temps livres et journaux
aucune épouses d'ambassadeurs connaît
les mêmes problèmes que d'autres femmes
sco vite absolument absolument
ils ont pourtant connu la belle vie
celle des privilégiés sous le régime
soviétique depuis la retraite en 95
ils ne peuvent plus s'offrir à
restaurant et se déplace uniquement luce
avec la crise leurs revenus se sont
effondrés ils partagent les angoisses de
toute une population particulièrement
touchée celle des personnages nona
disputent les prix elle s'est refusée
faire des stocks elle n'a pas voulu
céder à la peur et la pression fait de
voir ces files d'attenté
tristesse était crispé le cordon pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
crise les prix ont pourtant baissé
c'est grâce à primakov l'espoir que la
crise nous aurions à un gouvernement est
un gouvernement intelligent il l'espère
mais sans illusion aujourd'hui la russie
récupère même les symboles des rêves
perdus de tout un peuple
nous sommes ici devant l'une des
nombreuses gares de moscou c'est bien
symbolique entre la capitale et ses
provinces mais ces liens ont tendance à
se distendre dont il est vrai que moscou
fait figure de privilégié aux yeux des
provinces et elle en effet qui a le plus
bénéficié des investissements étrangers
alors que les provinces elles voyaient
leur usine fermer les unes après les
autres
thierry thuillier et philippe luzzi se
sont rendus à toul à environ 120 km de
moscou
c'est son univers quotidien depuis trois
ans et son licenciement
une déchetterie industrielle
pour survivre sacha vient ici retourner
la terre et creuse comme un damné à la
recherche du moindre bull mais talent
qu'il espère vendre tous les jeunes en
jeu peut creuser pour 20 ou 30 euros
je ne peux pas trouver du travail les
entreprises embauchent des plus jeunes
que moi
20 ou 30 roubles 7 environ 10 francs
avec lesquels il doit faire vivre sa
famille pour lui l'urgence en russie
tient en amour
ça peut avoir du travail pour pouvoir
manger on nous paye à l'heure
il y a pire encore que le sort de sacha
à tous là à 200 km de moscou
la crise n'a pas fait de quartier
chômage et salaires impayés les ont
poussé jusqu'aux marches de la ville
certains sont là depuis quelques
semaines d'autres depuis des années tous
ont encore un foyer
j'ai une famille à nourrir
je cherche la viande du pain et des
bouteilles comme mise et où manger avant
vous tourner sans d'afrique maintenant
vous fait ici
j'ai honte pour ceux là sont brisés et
il faudrait beaucoup plus qu'un nouveau
gouvernement pour leur redonner espoir
ici personne ne croit que les choses
vont s'améliorer
les usines ferment les unes après les
autres
et celles qui fonctionnent encore dix
ans
même tout lattier remède un des fleurons
de la sidérurgie russe n'est pas épargné
en deux ans les effectifs ont été
réduits de 25% et de nouveaux plans de
licenciements sont déjà prêts ce serait
une question de vie ou mort à son
entreprise
on doit désormais apprendre à vivre avec
ton moyens on n'a plus du tout la attend
sans illusion les prochaines décisions
politiques
la ville a payé un trop lourd tribut aux
réformes libérales pour croire à des
lendemains qui change
alors gilles rabin vous avez suivi de
cette crise politique économique ici à
moscou une crise qu'on ne sent pas tant
que ça dans la ville il faut dire que
cette ville est très belle elle a été
rénovée elle s'est développée et puis
j'ai un temps extraordinaire oui cdt
année qui commence ici on l'appelle le
printemps mais jeune fille vous savez ça
dure jamais très longtemps après arrive
l'hiver et cette année en russie
difficile et rigoureux économiquement
bien sûr et socialement car après la
crise financière vont arriver les
faillites en série
les fermetures d usines et les
licenciements massifs la russie va
souffler d'autant que le gouvernement de
monsieur primakov sera un gouvernement
de coalition allant de la droite à la
gauche et que les ministres mes médecins
appelés au chevet du pays malades ne
sont d'accord ni sur le diagnostic ni
sur les rebelles merci gilles voilà on
arrive à la fin de cette page spéciale
sur la russie sans être exhaustif je
crois que c'est ce qu'il fallait dire ce
soir à moscou
bonsoir
retour en france avec sur les champs
elysées la plus grande exposition
aéronautique jamais réalisés en ville
patrice pollet men ribeiro sur la place
de la concorde
la pièce maîtresse de cette exposition
le rafale c'est vrai qu'au sol il est
aussi bon qu'en l'air le rafale c'est le
chasseur plus chef du monde
l'un des plus perfectionnés ou six
avions suit la pensée des pilotes
c'est une facilité pour un pilote
expérimenté bien sûr rare puisque
l'avion est toujours dans son domaine
est optimisé pour restituer les
meilleures performances par rapport à ce
que nous lui demande deux pilotes très
entouré
l'avion de louis blériot en 1909 c'est
l'exploit la première traversée de la
manche
blériot entre dans l'histoire on voit
des appareils dans une vision rêvée
contre les gamins pour les voir pour de
vrai c'est un peu du rêve de l'enfance
qui est devenu réalité
la proximité avec les avions est la clé
du succès de cette exposition on
pourrait presque toucher le tigre
d'eurocopter le voir si près de nos vies
de ce métro comme
piloté par un temps et je pense qu'ils
ont encore des bonnes sensations mais
jen kore
aux abords du tigre les sensations ne
manquent pas dans sa catégorie
il est le seul à pouvoir effectuer ses
figures
ce champ d'aviation c'est presque le
salon du bourget il faut une bonne paire
de chaussures et comme à l'armée se fixe
un objectif
et surtout ne ratez pas les seul avion
qui ne vole pas de la ferraille soudé à
coup de chalumeau par un artiste que les
d'argentine ainsi se termine ce journal
je vous en rappelle les deux principaux
titres le congrès aux etats unis
décident à la très grande majorité la
divulgation au mondial sur internet du
rapport mettant en cause bill clinton
puis la douma voté aujourd'hui
l'investiture de gagny primakov le pays
se dote d'un premier ministre après
plusieurs semaines sans gouvernement
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet puis le point route valérie
maurice de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit damon je vous
retrouve demain dès 13h merci de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sur pente
ce soir prenez l'abonnement